for our guests he's running a little
late but [ __ ] it we're still gonna take
it to the hoop were you excited because
of star wars yeah oh yeah can't you see
me jumping up and down i'll give a [ __ ]
about it i know what you did all day you
watched star wars
i was telling you what i was watching
claire when i left the goddamn house i
was watching that nirvana kurt cobain
what is it on it's on hbo okay and uh
i think it's on hbo go but i saw it
again tonight at nine i was taping it
from the beginning i watched like uh
35 minutes of it my wife was watching
the baby was in the room
she was watching some tv on her thing
laying back you know
and uh my wife and i were watching i was
getting ready for the podcast and my
wife said to me that
she had never seen two people more
consumed than drugs like she was getting
high when she was pregnant with that kid
or whatever she was doing heroin and it
was showing all this [ __ ]
and it's funny because i was sitting
there thinking to myself you know i
looked at my wife and i don't know if
you knew this i was just as consumed in
2006 and five and four
and she goes no well how do you mean and
i go there's people who
do you know who are hobbyists they get
high on fridays
there's people who do drugs who might
get high on thursday and sunday
and then you have hobbyists hobbyists
you know they're they're people that are
hobbyists they don't know what they're
getting themselves into yet
and then you have people that it
surrounds their thought
you know i don't know how i made it
forward in comedy because cocaine was
always surrounding my thoughts
cocaine and comedy were always neck and
neck you know i woke up thinking about
where i was going to do a spot tonight
and what jokes i was going to say but in
the same way i was thinking about where
i was going to get 60 bucks for a gram
of coke well don't you think it held you
back
absolutely [ __ ] absolutely
abso [ __ ] lutely it held me back but
think of it
i mean there's a lot of people who get
high and can't even [ __ ] walk around
right i was still making progress lee i
was still making forward steps in many
directions oh no in total and i mean to
stick it out and kurt cobain was one of
the biggest rock stars ever so if he
wasn't on it maybe he would have been
even like i'm just saying well it's the
funniest thing when he got into it he
wasn't that much into heroin that's what
the ladies were saying oh god that he
was and he got into the heroin after
everything came you know the the
handling of it how to handle
or i mean they were [ __ ] huge you
know somebody told me 10 years ago that
and i got pissed off and i was wrong for
getting pissed off i don't know who it
was i got into an argument with somebody
because they said that
uh
nirvana was as influential as the
beatles were and i was like are you
[ __ ] crazy and i
i think i called him an [ __ ] or
something like that and i went home and
thought about it i was wrong
and you know the only difference was
that nirvana
did
the same as the beatles in a shorter
amount of time
they really changed everything
everything died like that heavy metal
died up to that point that sound and
then that whole sound got consumed i
mean from alice in chains to sound
garden to [ __ ] uh
to you know hair of the dog whatever
whatever
how long were they around this is
unfortunate this thing started in 92
probably
with that i started in 92 you or 91 you
heard the you know mother love bones and
the [ __ ] like that and you were like
damn
damn this ain't [ __ ] bad okay but i
still remember clearly like i was all in
i was all in uh
i think never mind i don't know what i'm
i was in
but once i heard bad motive finger i was
[ __ ] in that's the one once i heard
the first uh pearl jam i was pretty
impressed i was like damn i like i
didn't hate any of it like i understood
it was a time for a change
but once i was all in one soundgarden
super unknown came out in the fall in
the spring of 95 i think okay
maybe 94. i could be wrong i was all in
you're probably right
no and then i moved to seattle
and like i was telling terry i don't
want you to think i lived in seattle
because i was cool and i just moved to
seattle because
i heard there was a great comedy scene
up there and it was something different
i was a fan of the seattle supersonics
when i was a kid like i liked the when
they went to the championship in 77 or
75 or whatever
so something about seattle i just always
liked you know and i had an allure to me
so when i went up there the music was
just a a cherry you know on the sunday
can i go see a lot of live music i'm not
gonna lie to you maybe a year and a half
i went to see three live bands
i had a great time it's not my cup of
tea you're only there for a year and a
half i was only in seattle 18 months
maybe 20 months that's a jam-packed 18
months
yeah it was a jam-packed 18 months a lot
of comedy man but
uh beans like i i met these two lesbians
that lived in josh wolf's building when
i lived in the building i'll bring josh
on and talk about him there were two hot
hot hot girls
one of their parents had money
and these girls basically got heroin
stayed in
got high and ate each other's [ __ ]
and they were hot as [ __ ] and i became
friends with them because they were pot
smokers
so i became friends i never disrespected
him i always spoke to them the right way
and one night they asked me if i had
ever gotten high on heroin i said yes
and they were telling me how they didn't
take showers with soap
why because it would unclog their pores
and you want your pores to stay clogged
so perspiration doesn't come out of it
so the heroin always is in your system
so when you eat chocolate or something
it activates it just a different world
you never did it with a needle right
no i did not no i did not i don't think
i could i would have died i think i
would have died if i was to shoot heroin
with a needle and i have to pull out the
blood and shoot it back into your vein
that's too much for me just that little
spurt of pain i would have [ __ ]
passed out did you see my arm from last
week no it was still a little black and
blue it still is i think that's just
then i went away oh no no there it is
you see it do you see the arm
do you see it oh yeah oh jesus yeah
it's still i mean that little pain like
and it wasn't that wasn't the blood test
that was the stress test the day
afterward
because they put a needle in
they put a like a little catheter in or
something like a
in your arm and they shoot ink
and they shoot so they can see
everything or something yeah it's like
an intravenous thing
and then they just shoot ink into it
without the intravenous and then later
on when i was in the stress test
they actually shot this uh this type of
speed it's not really speed i'm sorry
this adrenaline it's like an adrenaline
into your vein to see if they can raise
your heart rate up to 170 or 180
whatever the [ __ ]
they wanted to get it up to so that that
left the bruise
that little i'm surprised i didn't pass
out on that [ __ ] i am very in shock i
did not pass out on the elliptical not
the elliptical the treadmill they had me
on yeah 170 is high i mean i know that's
kind of around where you're supposed to
be for fat burning but i'm usually
around like 140 150 on there well you
have to it's something that they had to
push a little bit because they want to
see where your heart could go does it it
determines your age or something i
didn't i didn't ask them for the
equation
she was just explaining it to me that
it's something to do with your age times
two
and how do you get the results yet
no but he hasn't called me in so i don't
look like i'm dying any [ __ ] day soon
unless i eat like 10 pizza pies from
that [ __ ] i'm kind of nervous i have
my first doctor's appointment in like
four years next week what are you doing
nothing i just i i haven't had a
physical since i moved out here he's
doing a physical yeah i mean i'm paying
for insurance i might as well use it
we're right um this place in north
hollywood this
i don't know i paid 300 a month for
insurance and then a lot of people still
think it's like obamacare or something
so i don't know you're gonna laugh but i
i was on my insurance and i just started
googling names
and they have yelp for doctors so this
guy got a bunch of good reviews so i'm
going to him
let's see what happens okay god bless
you
you're not going to stick a finger up
you guys are going gonna do some lab
work
yeah i don't know good for you that's
good lee it's i mean i'm not you're
gonna see your numbers yeah you're at
you're 26 just to see where your numbers
are at you might come back and say dog
you got no cholesterol i'm sure no
[ __ ] problems but if he comes back
now you know what you got to work on you
know yeah
no and i don't think anything is going
to be wrong
um
but i don't know i've never really liked
a doctor
i said that and i don't i probably won't
get a needle
but uh it's just it's after four years
it's like kind of grown into something
so i just need to go
i didn't go to the doctor from
this is [ __ ] crazy i'd probably go to
a doctor from like 1982
like
2 000.
when i started dating terry terry made
me go to the doctor wow she had to
[ __ ] drive me i was i was my legs
were wobbling
for the sleep apnea my legs were
wobbling like i was scared and they told
me there's no needles involved
i'd have to do a sleep apnea test and
the doctor told me what to do yeah it
was great was any part of it like
embarrassment about the weight
it so ah when i walked in there yeah you
know
you know they see different people every
day listen right you want a doctor
that's honest with you okay you don't
want to doctor the candy caught it right
the reason why i go to dr solomon is
because he was honest with me the reason
why
i go to [ __ ] waxless because he's
honest with me you know they
the reason you know was very uh
i watch a lot of personal trainers when
i go to different gyms and should i my
hobby is to watch personal trainers and
how they
help people and if they're even helping
people you know and uh
the guy where hegan's at the guy that uh
teaches the uh systema this russian
stuff okay the english guy he's a great
guy
but i liked him right off the bat when i
was working out down there because one
day him and i were talking system has an
heart built around breathing
it's like a russian thing created by
monks and they didn't know how to heal
themselves so they started breathing
just breathing so system is a martial
art that's very
breathing control like confusing or like
what is that thing where they do in the
park uh tai chi this is no this is uh
when they they do different things for
energy so when they drop to the floor
they blow out their energy they get up
by breathing
so everything is controlled by their
breathing and a lot of movements it's
very interesting but i remember talking
to them when they going yeah maybe i'll
take a privacy and talk about breathing
goes for starters i got let's not [ __ ]
around here you gotta lose some major
league weight
somebody else wouldn't say that a
personal trainer and somebody else would
take that wrong i liked him after that
because he didn't tell me oh no no let's
just do this three times at four
thousand dollars and you'll breathe more
did it hurt your feelings at all when he
said at all not at all i i i like them
even more
i like to i like a person more when
they're frank with you you don't want
somebody to candy coat your [ __ ]
health right you know you don't want
somebody to candy coat you when you're
i'm trying to learn jiu jitsu i don't
and uh you don't see no progress you're
not gonna do nothing for the guy the
guy's not gonna come back to you in 10
days why is he giving you 95 hours to
walk around [ __ ] saw right yeah
that's uh i think that's you you were
joking around when i came in but
i think maybe once i've lifted weights
at the gym since i've been going since
june
and it's just the doctor's the perfect
example of it
whenever i have to do something like
that
i procrastinate and i get in my head so
and i can i mean yeah i like the
elliptical and yeah it's just
but it's
at some point i just it i don't know if
it's fear or what it is but i just i
don't know what i'm doing with weights
and i know what i'm doing with the
elliptical well like i told you listen
you're a smart guy
you know
and the the thing that you guys have
that i didn't have
this generation has is you have access
to the computer everything is on there
we can have a discussion right now about
a topic
and when you go home you get a cup of
coffee get a joint
get your box of shorts on and you go
online with a notebook and write
everything you need to do
keep starting this is the problem i have
with uh basically everything on the
internet
even when i was trying to just do a diet
if you read 10 articles there's gonna
they're going to tell you 10 different
ways and they're going to say every
other way is wrong so for someone who
doesn't know anything it's like oh well
what am i supposed to do then well go to
three articles don't confu you know we
have
sometimes we think ourselves out of a
decision that's all i do that's all
people that's not just you it's many
americans and i learned that when i was
selling cars
i'd say all [ __ ] aside what are you
looking to do
and they'd start rattling off you know
and i go listen first of all
you know i want you to look for a car
for your needs
what are your [ __ ] needs well my
needs are i'm really not making a lot of
money and i got to keep my payment at
140. okay so we got that need
okay what else do you need this car for
i needed to go to from here to there
point a to b it's not much 22 miles a
day
i got your needs you know
sorry about that people allergies in
california
are to a [ __ ] up time
they're just off the charts oh really i
don't get him i just bumped into a lady
i got him walking her dog and she said
hello
and she goes what's the matter why is
your eye leaking your allergies she goes
please i'm backing on the pills
i'm not kidding you people allergy
oh god i'm sorry i had a all-time
[ __ ] high the last two or three weeks
yeah but it's it's tough especially when
you're buying a car
because like let's say you say
i need my payment to be at 140 and the
first thing to come back with is 180.
well because they know you're [ __ ]
uh
they know you're lying as a consumer
you're trying to rob them too right you
know
i actually had a [ __ ] up sort of thing
happen on thursday and it's kind of
embarrassing but uh
i don't know
this is kind of what the podcast is
about so when i moved into my place
the electricity was just on
and uh
i tried to switch my my account online
and i just never did it
and it wouldn't work so and i never went
down to the office
and i worried about it for like almost
the entire year that i was there
and then i actually lied to you and i
feel bad i felt bad about it which if i
want to talk about it
on thursday when i got back i was
helping paula out my power was off i
never experienced that before
it's [ __ ] terrible
and i didn't have ac so i actually i
came here and i just hung out here i did
some work and then i went home to go to
bed
i almost i almost slept here but i
didn't want to get i didn't want to get
someone get here early and hear me um
but uh i went down to the office the
next day and i was really worried about
it like i actually got paranoid because
she took my license and she went to go
take a photocopy
and like a cop came down from the back
so i thought you would call i thought i
was going to get arrested for not paying
like an electric bill and they came back
and it was like 700 bucks and it wasn't
i didn't i don't want to pay that much
right now but it wasn't as bad as i
thought it was going to be
and i kind of wish like i had just paid
it like i just called them because like
yeah i call them and they don't answer
so like i get i gave up on it
but not having powerful weather for that
one night was [ __ ] terrible and i
thought i thought i was going to do it
for a whole weekend
i thought i was gonna have to do it for
a whole weekend that would have sucked
but no they turned it on that day but
i i was there you have to look at your
room and say to yourself what would i do
without power here
what's gonna happen after
an earthquake you have no power for four
days it gets hot really quick and then
i felt like i've
i felt terrible like i when i got there
the woman in line next to me like i was
literally first in line the woman behind
me
literally said she didn't have power for
30 days
and they won't take a plan
and they're just
they just want all of it and she doesn't
see she hasn't got paid for like three
months or something
and it's uh i've always really
i grew up in a very white town a very
like an affluent town but i purposely
worked in like more working-class towns
like when i was in line
four or five people came up and talked
to me one guy he just thought like i i'm
making enough money to pay my electric
bill he just thought i was broke and
he's like he was giving me numbers to
like a
place that will help you pay your bill
and that and i was just like
people are like that's like the last
place i wanted to be but i met some like
really like they were just like
genuinely nice to me but it was like it
was [ __ ] up like not having power and
i felt bad about myself for a little bit
but then i paid it they turned it back
on so it was only like
one night but
look at it you went back and slept in
the dark like a mook oh yeah
what else am i going to do right there
on the couch dude there's people here
all the time who's the [ __ ] they live
here too you think so i know phil these
people [ __ ] creepy people oh okay i
shot two weeks ago one night
and and there were [ __ ] people here
you said you came on a sunday and you
smell weed oh yeah they're they're
always here but i just i never know
i hate tvs and [ __ ] and cannons and
people taking bats with buckets these
people [ __ ] animals yeah but it's uh
it was just it was crazy man there's no
shame in [ __ ] making a mistake
and getting your [ __ ] turned off i
[ __ ] lived without a shower curtain
for a summer
every time i take a shower the kitchen
the bathroom looked like [ __ ]
titanic was in there floating
you know who who does these things
that's what it is to be young you know
you go through different [ __ ] phases
in your life and i'll never do it again
oh no you'll never [ __ ] do it again
it's it's horrible think of it what
happened in august 100 degrees
you know it's just a horrible helpless
feeling yeah that's exactly what it was
helpless you know and uh
people go through it all the time man
they're in between paychecks and they
lose electricity for two days
it's time to use those [ __ ] candles
yeah like i've never had my cell phone
turned off and like because i've been
every once in like i haven't had paula
for like the last few weeks she's just
been studying so every once in a while
i'll i'll get high or even i'm not high
i'll just go on twitter and start
talking to people it's like
like people who don't haven't had jobs
for months and it's uh
it's just crazy to me like
i've
i've never been that broke and it's it's
scary to think how you can imagine yeah
i've been very broke i've woken up broke
i've gone to bed broke you know i was
broke for a long
[ __ ] time man
was thinking about my 21st birthday how
i robbed a chinese restaurant
on my 21st birthday like i was by myself
no i'm sorry it was my 22nd birthday
i was by
myself and i robbed the chinese
restaurant
did you rob like the cash register you
just ate and left i i robbed the cash
register i didn't [ __ ] have a gun or
anything
you know to use
uh
you know who does something like that
that's an animal that's a terrible worth
it i have to laugh at it now you know
you think i like telling those stories i
mean i lived in an office
half the size of this in seattle
you think i like telling that story you
think i like even thinking about having
to get up and [ __ ] out the window
and piss out the window and
[ __ ] the cleaning people come in the
middle of night and i'd be in there all
coked up and i turned the lights off and
locked both locks and [ __ ] and they try
to be getting in to vacuum the office
and empty the trash are you [ __ ]
kidding me and i'd be on i didn't even
have a couch
i had a a blanket on the floor
with a blanket and a [ __ ] pillow that
i would sleep on
with a desk and my clothes hidden under
the desk
in boxes like this so if anybody did
come and i had a 1-800 number
because i was selling [ __ ] sports
information out of it
you have no idea this is what i did for
comedy but this is also what i did when
i was consumed by the blood that was
part of the consumption i dealt with
that lifestyle so i could still get high
four times a week [ __ ] if i didn't get
high four times a week that's 200 that's
800 a month at least i had an apartment
and food in the refrigerator i said [ __ ]
it i'll live in a corner
so i could do my little addiction
[ __ ] thing it's amazing how quickly
stuff piles up like bills and there's
always something unexpected like i like
the day before i was looking at my
credit card bills like oh i've
kept it pretty low this month that's
gonna be cool
and then it just it's uh
it's amazing how hard it must be for
people who get in that position to ever
work their way out of it
i mean that must be what happens when
people decide to be drug dealers listen
i was complete i was pretty much broke
from 1992
to 2005.
when i got the longest yard all the
longest shot did
was
all the longest yard did was put
band-aids on the debt that i had
acquired already like over the years
okay so when i came out here i had this
chunk of debt right then i got the taco
bell commercial
and i paid like a quarter of it off
i paid a couple credit cards that had
been bothering me i paid a couple
creditors off that had been bothering me
i paid a couple personal loans from
people that i owed money to for drugs or
people who had helped me out and a bad
time i sent the check and then i
apologized and i skipped down i did
whatever
[ __ ] i did
and then from 99
i was broke i went on the road with
jodie ferdi we did those 10 weeks
this is after i lost all my clothes with
carol
what happened to your clothes my car got
towed but all my clothes and headshots
and boxing stuff and tapes and
everything i owned got towed in that
[ __ ] car
you know i went to miami
i told you people live here
and i had to start from [ __ ] scratch
actually 350 a week working as a house
emcee
at the miami improv 350 a week tuesday
through sunday
okay
how many shows [ __ ] tuesday through
sunday one two three
five
eight nine shows for 350 [ __ ] dollars
for you people who want to know that's
like 30 40 bucks a show okay exactly
they gave me the condo so i would snort
half of it and the other half i would
buy clothes at t.j.maxx
one of those dumb places what's the
other one that sells like pants for
eight dollars in a buckle ross
the other one the other one that uh
kohl's fault
i forget anyway
that's what i did for about [ __ ] you
know i just went on the road and i
chiseled away money money a little bit
of money a little bit paying child
support some months not some months not
paying [ __ ] child support i mean it
just did not [ __ ] end did create i
mean this is kind of a stupid question
but like
how much stress do you go through with
that because i go through a little bit
of justification here it is
by that time i wasn't getting stressed
no more i had given it up in 93 i knew
that you're dead you're in debt i'm
gonna be
i'm a comedian right this is what i'm
gonna do i'm gonna become a comedian in
94 i said all this deck could suck my
dick there's no debtors prison
i'm going to start doing comedy
this is what i'm going to focus on i
don't have a phone number i have a pager
i don't have a website they can't find
me so you never got worried about like
especially the taxes thing because they
don't they put wesley's is it just
wesley snaps made so much money for you
they didn't even care right okay listen
when you're making uh you know 10
million dollars you better pay taxes
okay but when you're making eight
thousand dollars a year they're not
looking for you you're not going to jail
but you you didn't feel like a con like
you weren't constantly worried about it
like it would come up
when i got into comedy i made a decision
in 93 like in 90 like i told you i just
got my american express card yeah 20
years
when my american express card got
canceled listen i came from
money and then i lost money and then i
became nothing and then i went to
college and i started getting loans so i
started getting credit cards sent to me
my biggest job then was to keep those
credit cards paid i paid those cards
before the bill came like i'm one of
those [ __ ] i didn't even wait
on the bill if i went out on monday and
i spent 100 on that card by wednesday i
was sending 150 back i'm one of those
guys
when those cards got taken from me lee i
got to be honest
that was one of the biggest heartaches
of my life i had 10 credit cards calling
me at different places oh yeah i go to
rouse and i get a call at ralph's joe
diaz line one high hey this is joe from
discover i never got your payment what
it was that heavily
they were calling me at comedy places no
way yeah man they were calling me at my
[ __ ] comedy place my first
wife or you know how embarrassing that
is no i would come in the bartender said
hey joe called for you three times he
left an 800 number he wants you to call
him back tonight he's gonna be there
till midnight
you know how [ __ ] embarrassed i would
[ __ ] be guy
do you have any idea and i did that
and then finally i just dropped off the
raider in like 94
and my friends were getting letters
anybody i put down for a loan we're
getting letters always horrible
so i i disappeared from 94 basically to
98 was when i got back on the books with
that [ __ ] taco bell commercial do you
were you were you thinking
i'll just hide for the rest of my life
or are you thinking at some point i'll
get my i knew they were gonna come out
of their head somewhere you can't hide
forever especially with computers i just
hope i was prepared by the time they
showed up right that was what i was
praying for in that time in my life
and i just kept doing comedy kept doing
comedy kept doing comedy kept doing
comedy and then i would get
bumps and bruises here and there like i
was somebody would reach out and they
took eighty dollars from your checking
account or something
and bank of america no at that time i
was with the other one wells wells fargo
wells fargo somebody just got me for
like 3 000 bucks
some credit company and stuff and then
from 2000 when i moved in with terry the
reason why
terry is happy today the reason why i
look at terry because when we moved in
together there was two salaries coming
in and they weren't even equal to
[ __ ] thirty thousand dollars
so both of you yeah i was a waitress and
i was a [ __ ] comic making 15 a set
some nights i'd make 60 some nights i'd
make 85 but
something pushed me
you know something kept me alive in the
game a little movie here a little tv
role here
and we just you know but we didn't i
didn't make money with terry till 2008
we starved together for eight years
it's amazing even the money i made from
the longest sure i got paid out wow when
we
in 2006 terry took a loan out for 30 we
were 30 000 no
and we paid 650 a month to bank of
america
we can we consolidated all the credit
cards that was all the debt i had put it
in from the cocaine all those years
like just we were just in debt and we
took thirty thousand dollar loan from
bank of america and we paid in two
[ __ ] years it's six hundred a month
or something we started sending like
[ __ ] triple payments
i would go on the road and just [ __ ]
once i stopped doing blow the house
started making money
so i stopped doing blow in 2007 the
house started making money in 2008 like
profiting like we were just sailing each
month we were losing 400 a month
probably probably yeah you know
borrowing from peter the people
and then once i stopped doing blow i
went on the road heavy i booked a couple
of movies
and we started eating okay the cats
and we started buying clothes you know i
lived off free clothes i lived off
fat daddy
big daddy you sent me clothes and boxes
it was amazing terry used to make forty
dollars a [ __ ] night at the comedy
store on the weekends 100 maybe 120 you
know but during the week we lived off 40
hours
it's amazing you didn't give up because
i heard this i don't know the exact
number but i was some news story they
were saying they say unemployment's five
percent but they don't count to like the
however many people just stop looking
for work
like i don't even know what you do at
that point if you can't claim
unemployment what would i do if i gave
up so you're telling me right now
there's no jobs
so here i am as a comic i'm struggling
what do i do try to get a [ __ ] job
no you keep believing in what the [ __ ]
in your heart
and you know event you see the people
around you starting to snap
you're like okay i came up with steve
runs easy i came up with this guy
they're starting to see some daylight
and all of a sudden little by little
instead of working once a month
you start working twice a month you know
instead of working
twice a month now at booking one tv show
every four months
now you book a tv show every other month
i mean if you look at my [ __ ] imdb i
got some work on that yeah ain't no
[ __ ] joke i worked for a long time
so
i know i listen man i know
what it is to be broke from [ __ ] drug
abuse i know what it is to be broke just
because you have a bad month
that's why what what do i say you got no
time to [ __ ] around
yeah you know listen this life you got
no time to [ __ ] around that's great i
mean you see somebody who's doing it you
cheer for them that's great yeah go have
a go look at me okay you're going to pay
for this and you're going to lose the
weak salary and you know
everybody wants to party and be [ __ ]
johnny rotten and you know you pay for
everything
i think when you're young i feel you
should jump on it this is what i didn't
do
if i could do it all over again i would
have jumped on it by the time i'm 29 i
went out of business
27 26 i would add a couple businesses
because it doesn't matter even if they
fail if you start three of them two are
gonna fail you're gonna get one of them
right yeah so that was it that's your
college [ __ ] degree
and you make your own hours and it's
easier said than done but it could be
done people have done it
i really wanted to go see the new
avengers movie this weekend i really i
really wanted to see it and i like i
tried like two or three times ago
but
finally like the stuff i started doing
is starting to take off i just couldn't
get out and i was thinking about it last
night i was like
i really like i really wanted to go see
and i i saw tons of movies last year
looking at my my credit card statement i
don't think i've been to a movie yet
this year
it's uh it's crazy making those choices
it's not choices you make sacrifices
sometimes and you weigh
what am i getting from this compared to
yeah we all need entertainment in our
lives and we all need to
uh put something else in your mind
beside what's in front of you
but
i don't know as americans i think that
there's
too much party time and there's too much
[ __ ] complaining
like everybody wants to party and
it's always something you know and then
when i ask you to work on saturday you
cop a [ __ ] attitude it's like office
space the guy would cop an attitude but
everybody's looking for money but nobody
wants it's the same right thing that we
deal with every [ __ ] day everybody
wants to go to heaven but nobody wants
to [ __ ] die
you know right and everyone like
everyone's complaining about the fight
that just happened last week at the end
of last week and each guy made over 100
million dollars so
i mean you're contributing to that like
they were selling hats for 500
people were spending thousands of
dollars on seats for that ticket when i
was in high school i got this job
at massback century hardware when i was
in high school
there was a job i i i quit high school
like my senior year i said [ __ ] it
and i got a job boxing uh stuff from
sentry hardware for orders to get
shipped
so when lee's hardware store wanted
22 feet of chain and this i'd box it and
then there was an opening for night
shift and it was 7 to 4 am
and i remember thinking that's crazy as
an 18 year old i'm gonna lose my
nightlife
so guess what i did i took the job
just to prepare me for the future
just to prepare me to let me know that i
wasn't missing anything
you know and there's times i would work
on a thursday and my friends are going
what are you going to do tonight we got
an eight ball we're going down the
ladies night there's who is it down
there they're going to suck your dick
and i go to massback century and i wake
up the next one i call those guys
and they tell me how they were hung over
and how much of a great time they had
the next night i'd see him and it was
like
we survived nothing happened so then as
a discipline
i started staying at nights even on the
nights i didn't work as a discipline
like as a [ __ ] discipline i'd just
stay in on a friday night just to prove
a point and it would drive
my friends
crazy they didn't believe me
where were you last night i stayed in no
you didn't
no you didn't you were out doing blow
somebody saw you in the city at four in
the morning lee i swear to god i was in
bed at 11 o'clock stoned to the gills or
sometimes i'm not lying to you i would
get a grammar blow and stay home
stay up till four in the morning jerking
off and calling people and breathing
heavy on the phone and [ __ ] and i did
that too i ain't gonna [ __ ] you man
i did that plenty of [ __ ] times too
it would drive my friends crazy they
could not fathom the idea that i would
stay in
and then once i moved to aspen i'd stay
there tonight to watch tv with jimmy
burkel we just get stoned
so the nightlife i eliminated out of my
life
just to prove to myself i wasn't missing
nothing
do you know what i'm saying just to
prove to myself i wasn't missing nothing
both times i left colorado in 83 i can't
look in the eye and tell you i didn't
miss my [ __ ] friends and went in
snorting coke and going to the city and
going to seaside heights and going down
the shore i [ __ ] missed it like hell
but i knew i wasn't going to get nowhere
doing that i didn't know why at that
early age as much as i missed it
i didn't miss you know i never missed
cocaine i always did that [ __ ] that was
like my thing if i got to be away from
them at least i'll do coke and that'll
keep me [ __ ] together you know so i
don't know
i love movies lee
i grew up on movies it's not going to
the movies for a guy like me that makes
it special
for a guy like me that makes it special
it's the movie comes on it's getting
released at a quarter to 12.
you get up at eight
you do what you gotta do you make some
calls maybe you go for a run in those
days i go for like a run
and i get back to my house at 9 9 30 and
i'd roll a joint i'd take a shower
and i'd roll a big fat joint i get
[ __ ] stoned i rolled another one to
go
and i drive to the chinese restaurant i
get the one special i'd say the
restaurant opened up at 11
i get that 1105
and i get the lunch special plus an
extra order egg rolls and i'd sit there
and eat it by myself
and then i'd walk out to the car and i'd
smoke a healthy joint and i'd go to the
movie theater and go and buy popcorn and
some razor nets
and i'd sit there raising that [ __ ] yeah
and i'd be the first one in the movie
theater
you know how much pride you have to do i
did that for
i did that for [ __ ]
uh trading places i did that for the
evil that men do with charles bronson
82.
i did that for a trading play i did that
for the other one eddie murphy did with
nick nolte 48 hours
i did that you know what the best
celebration i ever had for what good
fellas when goodfellas came out i was in
a [ __ ] halfway house
i was in a [ __ ] halfway house
and i didn't give a [ __ ]
i did the same thing i went i smoked two
joints and i went to see goodfellas by
myself is it scary high
what good fellas yeah no it's
sensational high
you just [ __ ] sit there and enjoy
everything but that's not the point okay
the point was it was an event for me you
know the last time i did that was
yeah
17 18 19 years ago
just it just went away so nobody
appreciates the movies
more than your uncle [ __ ] joey you
know what i'm saying
on i want to be around and go downstairs
and open the door for this [ __ ] dude
monday [ __ ] light a candle for
the [ __ ] dead people in your life
let them know you're thinking of those
[ __ ] spirits they're surrounding you
[ __ ]
nate let's do this [ __ ]
and hurry up cocksuck i can't keep him
down for an hour look how high you are
you [ __ ]
you should be ashamed of yourself
don't forget [ __ ]
this weekend graham rapids michigan
then i got the week off then memorial
day las vegas
are you kidding me or what
old time podcast here lee and i started
off a little bit
and then we have a guest tonight nate
moyer green beret [ __ ] got
drafted by the seattle seahawks on
sunday saturday he's an unrestricted
free agent so
we're gonna have him on the show to talk
some [ __ ] with us tonight about his days
in the [ __ ]
army all the [ __ ] that goes with it you
know what i'm saying
nate moyer have a seat my brother what's
happening
look at him with his [ __ ] longhorn
pants on and [ __ ] we're ready to throw
down here and [ __ ]
what's happening buddy
put the earphones on i'm sorry put the
earphones on and stay close to the mic
all right don't worry they don't have
ear wax in them we just had a crackle in
here there we go there you go
what's up my brother oh man thank you
very much um no no no no it worked out
just fine we're not mad at you nothing
like that i pulled into unbreakable last
week to work out with dave and i'm
looking at you i'm going this guy looks
familiar but i you know i see so many
[ __ ] different people there i didn't
know if it was the movies i didn't know
it was football i didn't know what the
[ __ ] it was then when i go in
french dave pulls me aside and he breaks
it down i'm like oh all right dave
and then i went home and i think i told
my man lee did you meet nate moyer i
didn't yeah so uh this is like one of
the best [ __ ] stories i've heard in a
long goddamn time i appreciate that this
is one of the best [ __ ] stories ever
it's not a story to me you know it's
just my life it's just
i mean who would have [ __ ] thought
that uh
you know i mean i tried to read some
stuff on you
it was just [ __ ] you know what i
read it was like uh two people did a
publicity thing but then i just started
thinking about the things you did you
you weren't after it says you tried to
be an actor for a little bit yeah yeah i
came out here uh
you know i'm from a i'm from a long line
of
lawyers that aspire to do uh some some
different things you know my grandfather
uh from the northwest actually he's from
near seattle area which is kind of
ironic because that's where i'm heading
in a couple days here but uh he kind of
set off on his own and he used to uh
just kind of jump on trains and backpack
around and sort of like a vagabond for a
while you know and then uh he ended up
you know being a successful businessman
and then my father
um
you know he after college he he didn't
know exactly what to do so he went tried
to raise oysters in the bay area you
know he ended up being a uh racehorse
veterinarian and so then you know
i i get out of high school and i'm like
yeah i don't know i just had this
adventurous spirit or whatever and uh
so
yeah it's just led me all kinds of just
crazy places but
um
i i just wanna i love attacking things
you know i mean just like you know we do
in the gym you know you get in there and
it's like all business and you just get
after it and so that's just sort of how
my personality is you know
now in high school
what did you want to be your senior year
in high school
now let's get this straight you did not
play high school football no no i didn't
have a team at your high school right
yeah so what did you play in high school
i played baseball and basketball so when
these other moocs from your neighbor
were playing football what were you
doing what were you talking about my
school didn't have a team right so but
some of the other some of the other i'm
saying yeah the other ones that i mean
in the bay area it was a little so what
i went to i was just going to college in
texas and it's like football is it right
football is everything but there wasn't
so much so i actually had my high school
uh so i went to two different houses the
first one i was at we actually had a
football team but basketball was a sport
it's what everybody did
you know football was cool but our
basketball team was really good and our
basketball coaches were kind of like
discouraging doing both because the
seasons ran into each other so but i
always looked at the football team and
you know i looked up to those dudes
because you get to run into people you
know and uh it's a physical game it
looked like fun you know what i mean and
i'm not the most athletic dude i can't
dunk you know what i mean i'm a good
shooter but
uh football probably made more sense to
me at the time there but you know i
wanted to
play with what was the best sport at our
school and so i just you know stuck with
basketball but uh
yeah i just i regretted it i regretted
never playing you know it just ate at me
it was something and you know i mean you
aspire to do great things you know if
you would have never you know went into
the entertainment business at all you
know you had that heart but i'm sure
there was a time i wanted to try it i
wanted to try i'm sure there's a time in
your life the whole thing is when you
have that little thought the light bulb
goes off right and you're like me or
with like the same we sit there and go
what are the chances
they're slim to none
but
what if i don't try exactly what if i
don't try what if i'm 55 one day
in a [ __ ] even if i'm [ __ ] filthy
rich
but i didn't try what was put in front
of me i believe did we not talk about
this subject last week the what if yeah
that that was always that always
bothered me that was always the thing
that made me go no that's it i'm like
you dog i got up one day and i knew my
junior here i am from america i'm from
new york [ __ ] city i'm from hudson
county new jersey a stone stroll from
new york city you talk to anybody where
do you want to live in new york city
that that's 90 [ __ ] percent of the
people and i couldn't wait to get the
[ __ ] out of there right mike i would
look at the kids around me and what was
around me like oh they're great kids
god bless them but this isn't for me i
was like you right
what's this what's in colorado how come
whenever i watch
[ __ ] tv they always say
uh
eastern time this and then mountain time
what's these [ __ ] mountains they're
talking about
so do you follow me unlike you and also
i end up in [ __ ] denver right i'm a
cuban kid in denver like oh my god what
is this [ __ ] you know i'm from jersey
where nobody leaves nate right nate they
go to
atlantic city and then they go to miami
and oh we're taking our yearly trip to
atlantic city it's beautiful they're
closing it because it's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
hole right but you wear your white shoes
you got to see those jersey people so i
get when you say you had to get the [ __ ]
out of that yeah so now you're in l.a
after high school you're not an athlete
at that time no you saw raptor high
school i actually moved to san diego for
a year okay i worked on a fishing boat
down there and uh i just had to get
outside you know i'm right outside and i
wanted to no college in your future at
that point not not yet i was actually
taking uh
i took uh
a couple firefighting classes i thought
that was maybe something i wanted to get
into you know it was all
uh
it was all like i want to work with my
hands i want to be outside i wanted that
adventure i wanted all that so you know
i thought maybe i'll be a firefighter so
i took some classes and it just wasn't
for me at the time you know so i
kind of lied my way onto a fishing boat
you know tell them i had all this
experience which i didn't have and just
sort of bsed it and then uh i loved it
though you know i mean you're out there
on the water all day and
you know you don't have to think that
much you know what i mean but it's just
it's refreshing you know and and what
did you do
what did you do i was i was a deckhand
so it was like a charter fishing boat
we'd go out like 100 miles out and we're
fishing for you know these big tuna and
so i'm like
i mean i'm i'm rigging people's lines up
and then i'm also running around with
the big you know what a gaff pole is no
so it's long like bamboo pole with a big
hook at the end so people bring these
huge fish in and the boats you know 10
12 feet off the water they can't pull it
up over so you have to you know reach
that that that rod into the water and
then like try to hook the fish under the
gills pulled into the boat it's pretty
cool
and this is what you wanted to do right
after high school yeah i mean i just i
didn't even know what i wanted no he
didn't know what the [ __ ] he just got in
the plane and said he looked he goes
there's jobs yeah yeah that's what i did
i looked in the classifieds there's jobs
we'll find something
i don't know
tamar might be an electrician that's it
you just lie yourself onto the gig fake
it to you man yeah fake it till you
[ __ ] make it it's it's it's really
when you don't have a job after two
weeks at a new place
and people are cheering for you and
you're like yeah i'm gonna give it a
shot and your friend's like you're gonna
fail you're gonna hate it you're [ __ ]
determined you get whatever the [ __ ] you
get just to bail you out until
something you wanna do opens up you know
but [ __ ] it i'll get on the fishing boat
what the [ __ ] exactly so how long did
that last i did that for about a year
all right yep and then i came up here
yeah and uh you know i wanted to i want
to do a lot of things that in this
industry in this business the film
business just was exciting to me because
not just the you know the glitz and
glamour of it but just the i love i love
stories you know i love inspirational
stories and and uh
i don't know it just was i think people
in this industry too have the capacity
to do a lot of good things for the
planet you know people
people like revere these guys you know
what i mean and and now more and more
you're seeing these people these
celebrities and film and television not
all of them but some of them you know
that have
some sort of organization they're
they're pushing forward and they're
trying to you know do things for less
fortunate and that's great so i that was
kind of exciting to me though so i came
up here and i want to go to film school
and i wanted to act and do all these
things but
you know you can't just walk into that
it's a little competitive
and i had no i was 19 and i had no idea
what i wanted to do i didn't have
nothing man i had you know i came up
here like 300 bucks
and uh i started working at a movie
theater and just living out of my car
for a while you know i think a lot of
people had that story
until we got towed i was just telling
lee my apartment got towed oh by the way
am i good in the street right out here
yeah
all right good
uh
yeah so
so but then uh you know that 911 happens
and then everything kind of just
went from there just completely changed
you know me and
what was important to me and uh
but still that that adventure they'd
never left you know and that was a lot
of it that a lot of it pushed me in that
direction
um 911 made you join the army yeah it
did and i didn't join right away i
didn't join right away it was a couple
years after three years actually
actually after
i was way too young
like i was in seventh grade when 9 11
happened yeah
but i i'm not the kind of person that
would see that and be like i gotta go
over there like that that's that takes
like a
like a fishing boat kind of person i
guess
that's crazy
yeah i mean i did it like i said i
didn't go right away because i didn't
know
where i stood politically about it you
know you fed a lot of stuff
at that age at 19
at least for me i was very you know
uh
easily swayed i guess i didn't think
about things sometimes i just if it was
interesting to me or somebody you know
i'll enter into all these conspiracy
theories and all that stuff you know and
uh but then uh
i decided to to take a trip to i went to
the darfur in afghanistan excuse me
darfur in uh africa yeah in africa in
the sudan region uh between sudan and
chad
and did some uh relief work there for
you know a couple months and uh that
completely changed me you know that got
me
like i i gained my patriotism over there
because those people the way they looked
at us you know and just revered what we
stood for as a country
and uh what did you see that made you
just say
okay what i saw was uh it's all women
and children you know the men are
already killed or off fighting
for me you know what i mean they just
wanted there was generous they wanted to
just put me up and like hear stories and
were so grateful that i would come you
know to their place and i had guys
join the american army how do i be a
soldier in america like i want to fight
for you know
people in countries such as ours that
don't have anything like you guys do you
know i want to be a part of that so it
just
man i just became so patriotic in a
short period of time you know and just
uh so i finally realized how lucky we
were you know i grew up very comfortable
we didn't always have a ton of money but
my parents were able to provide
everything for me you know i never there
was never a really a tight time when it
was like
i had to worry about anything you know
whatever i wanted to do they would help
me
do and so it's not like that everywhere
obviously
and uh yeah so i came back and like i
went straight to the recruiting office
and signed up
and did you know you were going to be a
green beret or you just said
right there right there did you look
into it did you go online and see what
they do these were so i started looking
at looking at that as soon as i got back
i was like what can i do that i still
wanted to work with the indigenous
people you know i wanted to
you know to free the up uh excuse me
oppressor bear is the special forces
motto and it means to free the oppressed
you know so that's what i wanted to do
that was like that just hit me
and uh you know i wanted to work work
with these people i didn't i didn't want
to just go into uh you know someone's
country and not actually
uh understand the situation through the
people there and
and that's the main thing that special
forces does is
uh we're fully embedded with them you
know we train with them we train them
we live with them and then we go fight
missions and go on missions with them
and uh it's cool to see that side of it
when you meet you know there are a lot
of people in their country that are
um
that want to develop and they want to
change and they want to get better and
they want to improve their quality of
life you know and you don't have to and
they're smart enough to realize you
don't have to
you know throw away the traditions and
religion and all that to do that doesn't
mean you need to become an american you
know you can just adopt some of the
values that we have and let us if we're
there trying to help you you know and so
that it was great to see that kind of
stuff and so i anyway i read a little
bit about it
i knew it was a long shot but i was like
man i'm just going to go for it so you
you where was the recruiting station
where you went that was back in the that
was back in the bay area in the bay area
and then you got station where for basic
in uh fort benning georgia okay that's
where you go if you want to be a
yeah
or if anybody anybody in the anybody in
the infantry it's like it's like an
infantry school yeah so you go there for
basic
and then you go to airborne school also
there and then if you you know trying
out for special forces then you go to
fort bragg north carolina and start
go to selection and you got to pass all
these steps you know it's how long did
the whole process go about a year and a
half wow yeah and you're a full green
beret
and then where'd they ship you to first
first i was sent to okinawa japan that
was like my duty station i had a cousin
there did you yeah she was in the air
force she was at kadena air force base
yeah yeah there you go
so yeah it was out there how beautiful
is okay it's amazing it's amazing it's
uh so first of all that base is the
smallest it's the smallest army base in
the world i believe it's called tory
station it's just
special forces battalion and some mps
and uh but yeah that island's gorgeous i
mean it's like it's the hawaii of japan
i guess you know there's a lot of
weddings out there and all that stuff
you have to have permission to move
there somebody has to sponsor you
people live there too there
i know that yeah you just can't move to
okinawa for me to move to okinawa let's
say you uh decide to stay there after
the base there right i have to go
through you and you go yeah let joe and
you have to sponsor me
uh it's the place where people live the
longest
i think the average absolutely something
yeah yeah they diet they [ __ ] to they're
90 they they suck they do the thing and
they ask this lady how many boyfriends
do you have and say i got two boyfriends
they have bodybuilding competition for
the japanese they have a
65 to 75 year old league
and they were interviewing the 75-74
year old guy
and he goes so what happens now and he
goes well now i go into the 75 to 85
year old league
and those guys are [ __ ] savages and
they showed these guys i mean they're
82. where did you see this oh my god
online and they have like old man skin
but no they get tested no juice right
this is just off the fish off the island
right and they're little yolk guys you
know and they're still doing crabs and
double bangs and you know vladimir's
dorsey but they have [ __ ] 80 year old
skin but it looks a lot better than not
having it right you know so i just read
i saw something one time on okinawa
and i looked into it it just looked very
interesting to live there just looked uh
i didn't know that army bases and air
force bases there to you guys just yeah
there's a ton of them it's like covered
in them
oh yeah there's a i mean
there's
marine bases all in the north part of
the island too
it's a lot ever since world war ii
they've had a presence there
but
yeah but i mean it's amazing that i mean
i knew they had that long life
expectancy i didn't know about all that
but yeah they it's got to be all that
diet because i mean they all smoke and
drink you know no they all do oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they just live forever so what
do they eat that's special fish fish
fish and vegetables
all day long and rice
but there's something that you know
i heard that the chinese
smoke more than we do
and their cancer is less than ours
that's interesting and they blame half
some of it on tai chi some that you know
they have different uh
you know ways of life
it's the same cigarette same like
filters yeah that's stuff
maybe they're even [ __ ] stronger you
know chinese people they smoke those
things to the [ __ ] finger yeah so now
do you get deployed out of okinawa so
yeah you can i was actually
i was actually going to uh
i was going to go
to the philippines for like a year and i
really want to go to iraq and
afghanistan you know because that's
that's where we are needed most and
that's where you know i wanted to go the
most austere environment possible you
know what i mean i wanted to like get
after it i had all this training
and so
right before
it's so scary to just think about
it's great though man
it's great but uh
yeah so
i i didn't i was about to go to the
philippines for a year and i was kind of
bummed out about that so
um i actually tried out for another unit
and we can't really name
and uh i made it into their selection
and did some of the training there i
didn't have any deployments under my
belt so they didn't deploy me with that
unit but what they did was
send me back to a special forces team in
colorado springs that was going to iraq
in like a month
so i kind of just over the course of a
couple months kind of got my way on a
deployment which is actually what i
wanted to do and then
um yeah so iraq was the first place i
went first deployment how long were you
over in that area of the world for i was
in iraq for that first time for 10
months and then you came home for a
while yeah so
towards the yeah i came home for a
little while and then i went back out
there
and towards i guess the end of my last
deployment is when i kind of decided i'd
been in for five years and i was like
coming up soon was either i re-enlist or
that i go back to col you know finally
go to college
and uh so what i did at that time was
um
i started applying for schools and i got
into texas and then when i went back i
stayed in the national guard so like
while i was at texas you know i would
they would deploy me in the summer times
while i was playing football and doing
all that and then
uh
so i could keep serving but but go to
school it was kind of a now or never
point do you start to go away one week
in the month
no i i i would do in the springtime i
would do that i would do the training in
the spring okay in the fall they kind of
let me go because of football and stuff
like that
and then i would as soon as spring
ball's over you know the way they do it
in college and probably the high
school's doing now too in high school
you know they got that uh you know your
spring ball
yeah coaches can't be on the thing just
uh no for us for us we could we could we
can you know
something yeah the ncaa you get like 15
spring practices or something okay right
15 of them and then you get a spring
game you know where you play the
offensive defense you know
so after that game now what [ __ ]
texas like you couldn't go to auburn you
couldn't go to jersey city state you
couldn't i could have
buffalo university you go to [ __ ]
taxes yeah now when you how old are you
when all this is going on 29.
jesus [ __ ] christ 29 year old
freshman
i'm 25 and i'm a colorado i did the same
thing
i was like you know what first off today
and this is something you'll appreciate
if if you get married and have a child
and your child comes to you when they're
18 they're gonna go hey dad
i don't want to go to college are you
gonna be pissed off
after what you've done in your life yeah
i look at my daughter i have a
two-year-old i'm 50 [ __ ] two so it
could happen at any time my wife's 46.
you know that bullet that that [ __ ]
guns always got bullets don't let them
lie to you uh if you eat cake you're not
yeah that [ __ ] nut sack is always
ready to impregnate some freak
so uh it really is that nuts there's no
rest for the wicked there's no there's
nothing good those nuts never do nothing
good they never go on humanitarian
missions right your nuts never wake you
up and say we're gonna go feed [ __ ]
little kids with [ __ ] not now your
nuts only work for one thing they keep
you fired up
and to shoot [ __ ] lows in people's
necks and [ __ ]
[ __ ] it this is american soldier we're
talking the real [ __ ] here
why become a soldier if you don't want
to shoot loads on people right or wrong
right so sorry roger here's why i
[ __ ] i love your story right then
so you're 30 [ __ ] years old you could
have gone anywhere you go to like the
best place in the world you go to austin
texas
you know you're standing on lining
barbecue right you're [ __ ] going out
downtown you're in college
you know
i've been to from stand-up i travel
there ain't no better looking women in
the world in austin [ __ ] texas i mean
i was just staying in february it's a
beautiful place
so here you are in texas
you know
you walk on
never played football before
no are you [ __ ] kidding me
did you have to try out it was that
regret thing like we're talking about
right okay so yeah when did you get the
it's the in and so somewhere in this
[ __ ] sudan jungle you're sitting
there you go you know what this is
getting boring for me you know i'm gonna
go to texas and play football with those
savages i never got bored i never got no
no no you know what i'm saying okay
no so i was coming towards the end of my
deployment and it was like
you know i was like now i never moment
as far as going amazing you know i had
to go it was like
you know i'm yeah 29 i'm not going to go
any later if i don't go now i'm never
going to go so it was like i'm going to
go back to school and you know if i'm
gonna go to school especially at ut you
know texas had some of the best uh
uh like veterans benefits like gi bill
and all that it's different from state
to state so i kind of shopped around
this and found out that texas was kind
of the best and then you know i'm in
iraq and i noticed that
you see that longhorn emblem more than
any other logo really you know from on
the soldiers obviously the dudes are
always wearing their you know texas
longhorn hats and shirts and stuff like
that
and so it was sort of like the military
team you know and uh
so i applied to school i got in and then
i was just like all right man i'm gonna
walk on i'm gonna try out at least see
what happens and so towards that you
know before
i go i'm still overseas and so i started
like training out there in the desert
you know like on base but you know i'm
out running routes and trying to i'm
looking up youtube videos on how to like
you know how to back pedal and proper
weight training for football and all
that stuff but you can just go and try
out for like one of those division one
teams yeah i mean so typically you have
like a
typically they want like you're like a
high school kid is gonna have like film
that sends up and like are they gonna
get a referral from their coach
and
you know all this stuff for me i was
coming out of the army
i didn't tell them i didn't i hadn't
played before but what i did say was
uh
you know that
you know green beret looked me up i just
got off i just got off you know active
duty you know can i try out and they
assumed i played in high school they're
just like oh yeah of course i didn't
tell them i was 29 either you know and
they're just like oh yeah sure sure how
long were you in the army i was like i
was in about five years so they're
probably like
she's probably about 23 24 you know and
uh why not so they let me work out with
the team and uh i just you know busted
my ass at 100
on everything 110
and just beat everybody as you know as
much as i could on on every drill every
lift always doing an extra rep and
everything and
so they let me on the team on like the
scout team you know and then it's only
then when they kind of figured out when
i'm in the locker room the first day and
i'm having to watch the other guys you
know put their pads on so i can figure
out how to do it you know what i mean
so
you know a little bit of lying there too
like the fishing boat comes back to that
that's how the whole africa thing
happened too though i had to lie
i
i
i just flew over there on like a
commercial ticket i wasn't even with an
ngo or anything
what
yeah yeah and i just like
i like talk my way find a group yeah
yeah i i talked my way onto a u.n flight
and then flew across to where the
refugee camps are and just kind of
showed up and then it was like
you know just sort of talking your way
into a job and you know of course a few
people were upset about that but it's
all good i am very happy right now i am
i have tears in my eyes talking to you
just there's so many things about your
life that make me happy but the number
one thing is that you just don't give a
[ __ ]
you're a nice guy you came from a nice
house but for some reason some in your
dna has the same deal they have i just
never gave a [ __ ] yeah you can't it
doesn't matter it does people nothing
matters nothing matters
i was telling somebody tell you that you
know
uh
when i was young there was a show called
cheers i'm 52 it was a call and people
watched that show and also they started
going to bars
and having these bar families and and i
remember talking to a friend of mine i'm
like where are you headed tonight oh
it's nick's birthday and and
you know one day you stop going to the
bar and you realize that nothing matters
your life moves on
why not go for [ __ ] right you know like
i never gave a [ __ ] i never really did
once i you know those people that come
to you and go i'm thinking you're
getting married in the spring of 2017
you look at them and go i feel sorry for
you what's all this [ __ ] planning
yeah what are you waiting on or people
go i'm thinking about being 55 and
having a kid what what what's the deal
you want to do something [ __ ] do it
thought just makes you
what's the psyche yourself out what does
thinking do lee we're just talking about
that it kills you yeah it takes you out
of it it talks you whatever you were
going to do
out of it you know one day i was sitting
there
nothing was going on in my life i walk
into a [ __ ] bar and i see a kid
that was at the air force academy yeah
and i go what's up and he goes i got out
and i got nothing going on i'm moving to
colorado in a week to join my brothers
my brother went to brown yeah the
garbage men and something else out in
colorado just skiing
i said you know what you're looking for
somebody to help you drive yet i'll be
in that car with you that's how quick it
was there was no real thought you know
yeah i mean you always have 200 hidden
under a pillow yeah that's enough to get
you somewhere you know that in the
[ __ ] bikini and you'll get to
wherever the [ __ ] you got to get there
you know
i never understood all the thought all
the
the fear this podcast is about fear man
this is it that
you know uh
the longest yard they told me they were
looking for a star name right i went and
made a tape and sent it to adam sandlin
a week later he called me right i said i
don't give a [ __ ] what you're looking
for i'm telling you what the [ __ ] we're
doing yeah you know today uh we were
talking about some friday some lady hit
leah and wanted all these numbers about
the podcast and i told lee i don't give
a [ __ ] what she wants to wear back
monday yeah and i don't want to leave
like jesus joey
use the money you gotta slow him down
and play him on our [ __ ] field right
you always got to slow people down and
bring them to your home field advantage
and that's when you always win right and
that's what guys like you and i do i've
always said you know what so what [ __ ]
it bring this to my [ __ ] field when i
walk in there i know one thing that i
got to have the biggest dick in the room
even if i don't have the biggest dick in
the room i got the biggest dick in the
room fake it because i'm faking you man
that's it fake it till you make it and
then after that you worry about the next
[ __ ] thing yeah exactly so now you're
on a you you're 20 years old 29
and you're on this [ __ ] team as a
scout now what
and on the scout training team yeah yeah
yeah so i mean i'm on the team i dress
for home games okay you know
coach mac brown who was the head coach
of the time uh great guy you know he's
want to give me an opportunity and he'd
have me you know run out of the tunnel
with the american flag before the games
everybody on the team i mean every team
has a guy that does that and he would
have me do it every damn game because of
my you know background obviously
you know that was great but uh you know
i wanted to play and so
i kind of looked around at the different
positions and
um you know i was a safety at the time
you know defensive back and it's tough
to
it's tough to play
at that level unless you're pretty fast
you know and i'm i'm a decent athlete
and i work really hard but i'm not
it's a gifted you know speed demon like
these guys and so
you know i noticed that the guy that was
long snapping the ball was a senior
and his backup was a senior also and so
i was like well maybe i'll just learn
how to long snap i didn't even know what
long stamping was before i got to the
team you know what it is i know what it
is but that's just a crazy way to choose
a position yeah hey man he's a survivor
this [ __ ] guy yeah he knew that was
it that's it is that or another i can't
see my [ __ ] way i'm not gonna run up
against these 18 year olds coming out of
high school yeah they've been debating
for [ __ ] four years
tackling gorillas and group four
football i'm not you know it's just at
least your honor yeah yeah yeah
so it was just like i had to find my
niche and then who taught you how to uh
long [ __ ] this guy you taught
yourself tell me you went on youtube so
i could strangle the weeks exactly i'm
saying we were just talking you can
learn anything on the internet right
right you goalie but you look at 20 000
things because of your gentileness i
don't know why you're a [ __ ] jew take
it to heart cox sucker
go to two pages and make your decision
okay i told you before we were talking
about this
he goes i go on the computer but each
one has a different story so i get
confused like about for like referencing
one like let's say
how many videos did you watch to learn
how to long snap there you probably
watched like 10 and one guy would say
put your foot here and then one guy said
oh well those guys are idiots because
you should put your foot here well i
turned the sound down first of all oh
okay now just watch you know and i'd
watch that because i don't want it
because
just like you're saying people they all
have their own opinions everyone's got a
different way of doing something
but i would watch whichever ones look
the best to me like this guy's snapping
the ball faster you know what i mean he
looks the most consistent and i'll just
watch his body and then i'll go try to
emulate that you know sometimes i'd be
in front of a mirror just like getting
in that stance you know i mean oh yeah
and then i would have people uh grab a
cell phone and like videotape me and i
watch myself and be like oh man that
looks terrible you know but i know what
to fix so it was just self-coaching off
of a imitation really you know
but uh
i don't know i mean see i have
balls to do that but i'm also scared
like after i joined jiu jitsu i knew
that i had to start doing kettlebells to
get everything going right and i went
online i looked at a couple kettlebell
things but i got scared because i knew i
was missing something with my posture
and that little thing might ruin a disc
or
something and that's what i don't want
to do so that's why i took a
but for some opinions whatever if i'm
stuck you know like i said i remember
having to go to an encyclopedia that's
when everybody had the same opinion
because you only had one [ __ ] person
to read from that's it it was uh i
forget the encyclopedia company but now
britannica britannica those people don't
know dick
but now you could go online and you'd
get so many different opinions and at
least you could make you could make the
same hypotheses they're making it yeah
you know you come to the same conclusion
again
with just a couple things i i believe
that you know i believe that at least
you could read and get yeah some [ __ ]
knowledge it's an amazing time and
without the internet i wouldn't i
wouldn't be here as far as the football
stuff i don't think you know i i really
don't
uh because that's who was teaching all
my stuff who was teaching that online do
you remember who was teaching a bunch of
different guys i would watch so i would
look up the
nfl rosters and look up the nfl you know
snappers and stuff like that there was a
guy that played for the bears for like
17 years he just retired last year named
patrick manley
and so he was kind of known as like one
of the gurus so i would just watch him
do it there's a guy that snaps for the
eagles named john derembos who's got an
amazing story what he'd had to overcome
and go through and uh
and i would watch him and there's videos
of these guys like snapping footballs
through the windows of moving cars you
know what i mean and stuff like that so
i'm like these guys are obviously pretty
accurate and they know what they're
doing so then i would go back and watch
their game film go back and watch their
uh back when they were
coming out of college you know when they
had like footage of their
snapping that they send to the you know
their scout their agents send to the
scouts and stuff like that just watch
all those little things and
um even young high school kids and
college kids that are just
highly recruited or whatever i would
just watch them too you know because
they've all been coached on it and
trained and you know spend all these
money this money and go to all these
like snapping camps and all that stuff
so
uh i got the the freeway you know the
cheap way
pretty [ __ ] impressive man so here
you are playing for a division one
football team not no semi-pro bunch of
[ __ ] washed up alkies
this is you know
yeah
they're just alkies they're not washed
up yeah these guys well even texas you
know you're at the one of the best
schools programs in the [ __ ] world
right for football i mean that's
prestigious enough
you're there what are you thinking i
mean this is your second year you're
starting
yeah so yeah my yeah i started on a
field goal an extra point that year just
just field goals and extra points
snapping for that and then the next year
who is your quarterback colt mccoy this
is after colt it's atrocious was uh
case actually and case mccoy and uh
david ash they kind of split they went
back and forth yeah
so both good guys but yeah i'm friends
with good friends with colt though he
said he's a good dude he's on the
redskins now yeah yeah he had a couple
good games last year he really did
that's crazy like the long snapper
it's like kind of like the punters like
like overlooked but when there's a bad
snap like in the playoff game
it ruins the game it's the most
thankless job in sports probably
you know they expect perfection every
time no one ever says good job
you know but if you mess one up you're
like you're the bad guy you know that's
it
probably fired in the nfl honestly yeah
they don't really mess around with it
just one snap
so
that's
that's why no one else that's why when
there wasn't a ton of competition with
it no one wants that pressure you know
and and the lack of glory it's not a
sexy position you know but
it's kind of making it sexy it's kind of
crazy there's like an article they like
they fired a huge part of the jets uh
scouting scouting today
and like
with all of sports it must be kind of
crazy that when you get fired
everybody knows about it
it's like really true
like like if you had one bad game the
next day the headline so and so is cut
and they signed they sent two guys but
there's always an excuse
and there's always somebody who could
say well i worked with that organization
they're [ __ ] up anyway come over here
right we'll do the scouting here that's
what you have that's you know nobody
looks down upon you because it didn't
work out with a certain organization
maybe you weren't and the people you
know they fired five people so at least
there wasn't one particular guy they
fight but like right after the draft
well when do you want to fight you want
to keep them for another two [ __ ]
drafts well no then what's the point
what's the point
oh maybe they gave them a shot and they
didn't like what they drafted you know
listen man when you're talking about
that type of dollars yeah that type of
organization that type of pressure just
being in new york playing football are
you [ __ ] crazy
they've been getting tortured in the
press the jets
tortured since marc sanchez they've been
getting [ __ ] tortured
tortured listen
you know i i don't understand it's it's
uh it's as much pressure as you want to
put on yourself
i guess but i guess those markets are
just horrible to play at
those new york markets where it's
everything to that city right well it
could be great or it could be great if
you're winning yeah if you're [ __ ]
winning everything's good oh yeah it's a
parade people jumping up and down
but you know now you're losing and
you're going to the dry cleaner you
still got to go pick up your [ __ ] at the
restaurant you know where they used to
say hello to you now you're 018 you
think people are still saying hello to
your [ __ ] though as a matter of fact
by that point you weren't in disguise
you got a hat on with glasses and a
[ __ ] being the [ __ ] up nose order
and delivery yeah order and delivery so
hey man listen it's it's
it's it's you know look at these ufc
fighters look at all this [ __ ] that goes
on yeah you know every time you skip a
level
it's you're going up against the elite
of the elite you know when you go to
trial and
not against a bunch of [ __ ] guys that
were playing frisbee
these guys have been touted high school
football in texas
is all they [ __ ] have friday night
lights isn't that texas
they don't [ __ ] around down there
so the people who go down there have to
go down there with this added you know
this is it you're going up against the
best of the [ __ ] best you know and
then then you go to the pros how much
pressure is the [ __ ] pros
that's a complete and i did the longest
yard that documentary that's on right
now with brian bosworth i heard that
whole thing two days in the [ __ ]
jacuzzi ten years i really did i asked
him it was just me and him for the
weekend when the movie first started
shooting right nobody knew what was
really going on nobody knew the rules
only a couple people stayed for the
weekend
he was one of the guys that stayed you
know the first hour we talked about
acting the movie he did after that we
talked about oklahoma right then after
that we got you know after a [ __ ] day
or two we got into the meats of potatoes
so they were finding him for his game
shirt because he'd leave it out
they were finding him fifty five
thousand the [ __ ] his whole game you
know just you know he had to go to the
therapy afterwards but it was the whole
move
it had started at oklahoma with the with
the bars and the [ __ ] juice and you
know oklahoma was crazy that was great
oh did you see that that was a great
thing for 30. you know we don't [ __ ]
that's crazy
you know i'm not gonna have [ __ ] my
man here and insult them with some
[ __ ] harvey talking to my football
here
so now you do four seasons with them
yeah awesome
and what's the next move now so you you
graduate what kind of degree
i finished my so i finished my undergrad
uh i got a kinesiology degree
undergraduate and then i'm just now just
this semester i finished my master's
in advertising
and so uh but yeah after the end of the
season i got invited to play in an
all-star game in charleston called the
medal of honor bowl
and uh
you know one of the reasons i got
invited was probably because i was a
soldier it's you know there's there was
medal of honor recipients that they came
to the game and like we got to you know
hang out with him stuff like that so
um you know that that connection with
the military probably helped me get him
that invite to play in the all-star game
there but i went out there and once they
saw me snapping and they were like okay
this guy's actually pretty good and
there was a bunch of scouts that come to
all the practices uh nfl scouts and they
were like
at the time i weighed about 190 pounds
because that's what i played at in
college with all the deployments and
stuff like that i had to kind of keep my
weight down and so
they were like you know you put on if
you can put on like 30 pounds you should
just go for it you know what do you know
right now i'm about 220 i put on about
30 already
so i came out here and just
started eating and then training at
glazer's place at unbreakable
and uh
yeah training and eating and eating and
training and finishing my masters and
just kind of went for it you know and
then i got an agent and then uh did you
get an agent when you were here you got
an agent for the here from the uh bowl
uh no here when i got out here and now
what was this asian telling you about
the draft with your age were they the
negatives involved oh yeah obviously the
agent size was the two biggest you know
what i mean and the lack of experience
but he was like you know but the store
you got that story and you can snap the
ball you know and you're a pretty good
athlete for the position
so you know he was like let's do it
let's go i mean he's got nothing to lose
if i don't make it it's not like he's
spending money on me really
some agents will you know some agents
will do this and that but you know we
had a lot of help along the way a lot of
people like jay glazer and uh people
that were willing to you know do music
do me a few favors and you know and
really advocate for me as well
and then it just uh it just worked out
you know so
it was a good day saturday
and you are you got drafted i didn't get
drafted i was right after the last pick
in the draft i got a call from pete
carroll the seahawks coach
and uh i picked up the phone you know
and he was like how's it going you know
we'd like to uh
sign you as a free agent and uh as an
undrafted free agent invite you out here
to camp and
you know to compete for a job you know i
still got to go win the job that's a
another
i don't even i mean thought about that
yet because you know we don't want to
plan too much
you know just one day at a time so do
they do any teams keep two long snappers
none of them do nope
one no backup
if a guy gets hurt there's usually
another guy in the team that can do it
for the rest of the game and then on
monday they'll sign another guy you know
so
yeah there's only 53-man
man roster so for kickers punter
snappers they don't have any backups
well
this is uh
i've been blown away in a couple
different levels here
you missed the army yeah i do i actually
just got out february 23rd
so i miss it but i keep those
relationships up and i'm still going to
be so actively involved with you know
veteran organizations and non-profits
and stuff like that anything happens
that you could still go back i could
yeah i could anything it gets hairy you
could still make a call and go listen
i'm sitting here scratching my nuts in
seattle throwing a ball for a bunch of
momos let me come down and party you
know what i'm saying
let's get down to party and again let's
get the helmet on the knight scope yep
it could happen for sure [ __ ]
tremendous so you have nothing to
[ __ ] lose which is
what life is none of what nobody does oh
my god nobody does you know people think
we think we do but we just make that
[ __ ] up it's not real
you know what i mean there's not really
any barriers or obstacles
you know they're all they're just
imaginary it really are i started comedy
at 28 and i got out here people i get
too [ __ ] old
you know you'll last a couple years and
18 years in which people told you that
just stupid agents and people people
that aren't doing probably what they
they probably wanted to do what you were
doing quite jealous yeah
you know that you had you had the balls
in the heart to go for it i've always
loved deferring odds i love i always
love to hear the word no oh yeah i'm a
walking sound
yeah i'm a walking salesman
i love to hear the word no then i go
home
and i eat a roast beef sandwich and i
look at the mirror and i remember what
god gave me two sets of balls for you
know what i'm saying again they're not
gonna go in the [ __ ] and play the drums
and nothing like that nothing useful
so uh and then i do what the [ __ ] you do
i mean [ __ ] balls yeah balls don't
[ __ ] around they don't you know they're
only here for one good thing to get you
fired up
that's it that's all your nuts do
they get you fueled up for the [ __ ]
daily
but uh
i love all this [ __ ] i love all this now
lee was saying who else got drafted uh
the patriots i think it might have been
a long snapper too actually was he a
long time
yeah he got drafted actually he was in
the fifth round um yeah he went to naval
academy
and uh
so he you know he hasn't served yet he
went out of high school into the naval
academy you know to be an officer
and so he's uh but yeah the patriots
drafted him i think they worked out some
sort of a deal with the navy so that
you know he doesn't have to
get deployed or something i'm not sure
how it works but he's going to be like
more like a pr person for them or
something like that so it's good
recruiting for the navy now why you've
been here have you gone for movie
auditions and all that [ __ ] no
any pitch deals for you like
nobody wants to hear this story um yeah
no a lot of people do so i'm kind of
being you know i'm slow rolling that i'm
focusing on football right now [ __ ] yeah
no one thing at a time seller i mean
that's cool that's it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's interesting and
and you know if it's done right i think
there's something there definitely
because i know how much it has inspired
other people
and so
but that's something that's yeah that's
down the road i'm just sitting here
going that for years i've been selling
that i've been selling that an 18 year
old cannot make a [ __ ] human decision
i've been selling this idea for 20 years
that i know from experience that it's
too much to put an 18 year old at a
division one school and make them
[ __ ] learn and
girlfriends and sororities and
fraternities and just it's just too much
you're in your third year you've
declared your [ __ ] major
and you get your degree now and you're
like
i had a buddy call me today about this
look look today
but guess what dad's a dentist and
grandpa's a [ __ ] dentist so now you
got to smell bad breath for [ __ ] the
rest of your [ __ ] life because your
dad thinks it's a career of a lifetime
so now what do you do you marry a
college girlfriend she spits out two
kids she gains 80 pounds she ain't miss
america no more she's got blood clots on
her leg and [ __ ]
you know she wants you to rub the thighs
you're smelling bread breath one of your
kids plays the dru you know whatever the
[ __ ] and i'll tell you man think about
it now what's the average what's the
average [ __ ]
college kid coming out to the o
what's the [ __ ] average college kid
coming out to the oh i read that a year
ago i said it's at least 100 oh my god
what the college kid so now
you know what now i have to take a job
yeah now i have to sell my i have to be
a junkie all right i have to only give
you six months from graduation right
they give you a six month window until
you get a job then you get this job and
you got to pay back these [ __ ] loans
and they're raising the interest rate
and you know what this is why you see
alcoholism this is what you see depress
i could see it i [ __ ] was miserable
at 24 being married and somebody telling
you you have to do something what are
you [ __ ] crazy that's right that's
just rough
and uh
i i just i love this story because of
that then all of a sudden you're on a
shrimp boat [ __ ] killing fish out
there with gentiles in san diego then
you're like [ __ ] it 911 it took you
three years
but you went over there and you got to
see that i mean
you should have joey read your audiobook
like for when you write your
autobiography i'll
please what do you want me to say just
what you just said just like
i'm having that be the audiobook
god almighty and then you're [ __ ]
over there and one day you decide you
know what
i'm gonna give landmines a break
i'm gonna go [ __ ] play football for a
while with some people down in texas why
no no no let me you know somebody else
would have said well let me go to junior
college and start slow
uh give him a key here lee so he could
run over real quick while he's in the
bathroom i'll read the well we'll come
back no worries bro you got to do what
you got to do
if i was about to [ __ ] try out i'd be
drinking everything
gasoline everything
let me give some shout outs here real
quick my man nate goes to the bathroom
my girl jamie stanley joey p
justin s or justin g i don't [ __ ]
know one of the justin yeah one of the
justin's rich machine i think that's
machine mr gonzo
paul lynch michael harrison happy
birthday [ __ ] dj pharaoh i love
you too
and matt willis stay black
like i told you earlier i'm at dr grins
thursday through saturday
i'm also at the south point
[ __ ] casino memorial day
weekend oh [ __ ] and oklahoma city on the
30th
i don't know what the link is for
oklahoma city i'll give it to you
[ __ ] is that joeydiaz.net i have
no idea what are you torturing me with
questions you see i'm as high as you are
and you want to [ __ ] ask me questions
pretty interesting night tonight lately
this is a great night we had a nice
little chit chat
you got a couple [ __ ] uh
highs you got me really high
i got to get your harley why do you
gotta get me home you guys at night you
sit there like a half a [ __ ]
you know like one of the people you went
to help out in africa
all dizzy with flies on you and [ __ ] put
the camera away what are you taping
first
why are you doing a periscope i'm over
trying to read these [ __ ] things for
people yeah while he's in the bathroom
let me do a little shout out to the
sponsors also on it
number one in optimum optimization you
understand me we ain't [ __ ] around
here without it i've been telling you
[ __ ] for years you want to get
in tip type conditionally physical
mentally spiritually you want to be all
soul and mind it all starts with alpha
brain 100
money back guarantee we don't even want
the [ __ ] product back all right
shroom tech i use it before every
[ __ ] jiu jitsu roll if i gotta lift
weights whatever i use it today i did 35
on the elliptical and i did the upper
body
just like that okay zoomtext sports shoe
tech sport they also have shoe tech
immunity if you if you move around a lot
and if you shake hands with a lot of
shady people
shroom tech sport they also have new
move they also have supplements they
have they have the the t performance to
raise your testosterone levels on it
just go to the [ __ ] page i've been
telling you people free two years now to
stop [ __ ] around go to on it right
now.com look at the i can't help you
with the weights or the battle ropes
nothing like that you want to be
spiderman today on your own time i can
just help you with supplements all right
go to honey.com right now and press in
church boom and get 10 percent off your
order they also look into the stay on it
program it's a great program i wouldn't
[ __ ] lie to you people all right they
got so much stuff they got the the
the little fats that you put in your
smoothie the coconut it's tasteless
odorless i've been using it lately i
feel good my skin's not dry like it used
to be he's that babe i used to be itchy
at night no more itches anyway i enjoy
anyway on it
press in
church and get 10 percent off your first
dollar looking for the stay on it
program it gets delivered to your house
in the first of every month
dragon tv for you martial arts
enthusiasts you bad [ __ ] you
bump into tim kennedy down in austin oh
yeah right yeah yeah good guy iron
dragon thieves special forces dude yes
they're sponsored by uh nanotech the
people who created iron dragon tv my man
dave [ __ ] foley putting pieces
together for you go to iron dragon tv
right now if you like martial life films
classic martial art films not jet li but
the other guy
jackie chan what's his cousin's name
whatever i don't know i got them too ip
man yep man the fat man series enter the
fat [ __ ] cat they got all your
classics go to
irondragontv.com right now go to the box
and press enter
joey j-o-e-y and get two that's right
two free movies
free gratis you know i'm saying i'm
speaking [ __ ] latin for your people
tonight also for my main man dave
nailed it life.com aka let's give me
some items the best gummy bears out
there they will [ __ ] kill you 250
milligrams they put ash they put these
special cuban minerals they get off the
boat from fidel
these they even leave scared of them
they don't mess around because you
always make me at the head what do you
want to do
you're already high and they eat the
eyeball the whole thing i make you eat a
gummy bear head and you get [ __ ] all
crappy on me go to nails in life.com for
the best wax pen out there in the market
and what are you pressing
chris and joey joey diaz and get 20 off
so it's a 50 pen so if you get 20 off
that knocks it down a 40. oh [ __ ] there
you go for the best wax pen out there
right now oil and wax oil and wax i'm
sorry lee go to nailed it
calm right now also to my main
[ __ ] over at hittie sigs
the best electronic [ __ ] cigarette
out there they got cigarettes they got
cigars
they got non-flavor they got stuff with
zero milligrams stuffed with eight
milligrams nicotine with 16 24 million
you can pick your [ __ ] nicotine level
quit cigarettes you use a cigar in las
vegas you understand me you see this you
should be having ten of these when you
go to seattle you're blowing smoking
people's face you know what i'm saying
what are you here for you're trying out
for what [ __ ]
come back tomorrow anyway go to 86.com
right now
and press in joey's church boom and get
what 20
20 off these little [ __ ] tremendous
1200 guaranteed hit each guaranteed cups
where you're gonna get 1200 puffs from
one of those cigarettes to seven eleven
they're gonna do [ __ ] for you but get
you sick and put that isis electronics
in you you don't wanna deal with those
[ __ ] stay
with heavysix.com right now go to the
page and press in julie's church and get
20 off all right so one more
shout out to on it irondragontv.com
nailed it life aka aka those goomies and
monos and hideysiggs.com
gotta scratch my ear anyway
what's up my brother
so when do you blast off when is it
thursday
you go up this thursday and what starts
uh over the weekend we got a rookie mini
camp so it's just the rookies out there
we got like three or four days of
practice and then we go right into
workouts with like the full team uh
for
i think until the end of june and then i
think i'll be back here for a couple
weeks and then
back out uh for training camp and
preseason games and all that stuff and
then
you know trying to hang around as long
as i can hopefully all the way through
the season you know so i mean it's just
one day at a time
one snap at a time really
so brother i am blown the [ __ ] away by
the story and i have been from the other
day you know like again i'm blown away
at the age i'm blown away at the
uh football yeah the the uh not the
football but the army green beret stuff
but then again i'm blown away because
you don't [ __ ] stop
you know and and if everybody was like
you holy [ __ ] [ __ ]
nothing would exist there would be no
terrorism just because we get up and go
in the morning there's no thought it's
like automatically you know you know
what i'm saying i've done this i've been
here i like it i enjoy it i'm gonna try
something else now right you know some
people have a hard time trying one
[ __ ] thing you know
and i relate with you being 18 and just
getting the itch
no matter what all we got to do is hear
a certain story about our relatives
to really just push us over the edge
grandpa [ __ ] did i could do it no but
times were different you know there was
no roller skates then i don't give a
[ __ ] grandpa did it i'm [ __ ] doing it
too all right that's the biggest mistake
they make is let us know that somebody
in our family had the balls
to get up and leave you know you always
had that one uncle your crazy uncle went
out to california hanging out with those
gay people
you know what are you talking about yeah
so what they don't want to walk around
without sandals yeah people always look
down at that i've never ever when i was
a kid i was confused when i was in high
school right i knew i didn't have a
family i knew
that i would probably not get a football
scholarship or a basketball scholarship
i knew that i would have to get maybe
like a division nine school
like a junior college to take me on a
financial aid and maybe a pal right so i
you know i i didn't have options so i
looked around
and i looked around at friends of mine
that even went to the service
but when they came back on that first
leave yeah they told you how they loved
it
and things were great and they couldn't
wait to go to [ __ ] wherever
and then you saw him back and you're
like what's up
oh that [ __ ] place sucked you know
and i'd always go well then why join the
service if it's so rough on so many
[ __ ] people but then i realized the
friends i had were kind of like [ __ ]
weak like they went then they they came
home for that first leave and they just
missed mama after yeah like some people
cannot [ __ ] take it after yeah it's a
certain time i know a friend of mine
called me telling you because i'm really
disappointed about it i just found out
for 20 years that our friend had been uh
what's one of your discharge uh
dishonorably and i go you didn't know
that
i go he was living in san diego hiding
when he got cut he was working in
redondo as a bartender i go i knew that
they were my roommate and they would
talk meanwhile he was telling you guys
so i saw him back in jersey for the
holidays and i'm like
he's like i'm back home from the marines
i don't leave and i'm like i feel like
ratting them out but i felt bad i didn't
embarrass somebody but it's just amazing
so i was never
you know people just a lot of people
just
especially where i grew up those people
don't like leaving
that area they they fall into a
comfortable a comfortable comfort zone
i couldn't [ __ ] wait man
and i didn't know where i wanted to go i
ended up in colorado
because of the mountains i guess and
then once i got there i did the same
thing i took six credits at the colorado
mountain college just to keep my
knowledge on top of things you know
i was always uh i was ready to [ __ ]
join what's this it's a quote my buddies
text me that today because he is the
buddy i was talking talking with that's
kind of like yeah like this at the end
of your comfort zone
i don't know who wrote that but somebody
should look this guy up
neil donald walsh that's a beautiful
thing yeah life begins at the end of
your comfort zone you know you know when
you saw me i go to train with dave for
jiu jitsu i know dave since he's at
higgins
and uh we're tight friends and he gives
me a great deal and sometimes when i'm
in a bind like on a sunday right my wife
goes to church with the baby and i'm
catholic so i run down to dave and uh my
biggest fear is being on the bottom and
not breathing right and that's why i
kept going to jiu jitsu right now i move
a lot [ __ ] better you know i go to
him i go to i try to catch a jiu-jitsu
class as fearful as i am
that's what's kept driven me you know
tomorrow i gotta actually follow your
fear i [ __ ] faint every time i see a
needle that is the reason why i didn't
get up and go to the army recruiter when
i was 18. i told the guy i'd [ __ ] be
there he can't he was a friend of her
friends and we were talking and he goes
joe you don't need this [ __ ] you're like
well forget about everything i'll get
you on a plane you do whatever the [ __ ]
you want i was like okay i go what
happens because we give you a physical
oh my god
at that time i was telling lee i
couldn't handle needles at all yeah like
now i go and i put an ipod on and i look
the other way and yeah i breathe at that
point i just couldn't handle it and i
never showed and i got to tell you
something nate i was always
sad about that so i never showed for
that
i didn't join the service over a [ __ ]
needle right how embarrassing was i you
know
i didn't join the service over a [ __ ]
blood test you know
so i applaud you dawg you're a [ __ ]
savage of savages
appreciate that and i uh
i don't know there's something about you
that uh
i really want you to make it this is you
got this me too you got this like i
could feel that you got this i know
we're gonna all get good news and [ __ ]
you know it's uh
it's it's like a win-win you know at
this point i mean even if you know i
don't make it it's not failing you know
if you look at
if you look at what you know how this
all started and where i'm at i've
already won you know what i mean i
already i'm already
i already climbed the you know i already
climbed the mountain you know so i want
to go to vegas with you i feel like if
we went to vegas we make like 400 i
don't think that's a good idea i think i
feel like you're like you can't make
your luck in vegas like you can make
your luck in life but you you said
something about you i feel like we'd get
it
like
okay you had like some close story
i don't know man no lee this is just one
of those stories you talked about and we
discussed them this is the stories that
we like to hear this is it this is all
because of uh
you can't put your fingers on it you
can't say whether you just
didn't have fear or didn't have well i
definitely had fear just like you were
talking about though about
you know you got to follow it you got to
chase you you got to go after your fears
there's a reason you're afraid of it and
a lot of times it's because it's
interesting to you it intrigues you you
know what i mean and some some of that
at least with me it's that
you know
it's a fear of it
a fear of looking stupid or a feel of
failing you know or not working out the
way you envisioned it but
if you don't do that i mean my biggest
fear is regret you know what i mean that
that supersedes all that other stuff so
were you scared of going into basic no
no i wasn't scared i was uh i was
excited it's the same with this thing i
just was having uh i was having to talk
with somebody tonight and they were
saying you know
are you are you scared and i was like
are you kidding me like this is a great
opportunity you know what i mean this is
what i want to do
i'd be stupid if i was scared of it
obviously uh
it is you know it's i care about it so
i'm you know it's that good kind of
nervous energy you have you know like
when you probably went on stage the
first time to do standards
good because that's that's cause you
love it yeah i love it you know and you
still and that's like that good kind of
fear that good nervousness you know that
it's not holding you back in any way but
it's it just lets you know how much it
you love it you know and how much it
matters to you and that you're doing the
right you're doing what you're supposed
to be doing if you don't have that in
your life you know in my opinion if you
don't have that feeling that you can be
doing something else tomorrow morning i
wake up
and my morning isn't complete till i
find out whether or not i have a spot at
the store tomorrow night
okay do you know that lee about me
that when i wake up tomorrow i do the
usual things the wife walks the baby to
school
she comes back sometimes i go to the y
but i'm not settled until i see the
comedy store retweet the lineup
and then i call to confirm my time
and then the whole day i talk myself out
of it
like why i'm not gonna go to the store
tonight lee lee knows i have a spot i
always say you have a spot at the store
but i don't know if i'm going you never
know if you're going anywhere i swear to
[ __ ] god have you ever not going
uh a couple weeks ago i got stuck in
long beach i got caught in traffic i
mean that's a different beach i mean
you've never have you ever talked
yourself out of going though
ah a couple of years ago really a couple
of years ago that bothers you
still yeah yeah like you have this
opportunity
to play for the [ __ ] seahawks
and you don't want to show up to [ __ ]
seattle because you don't feel good or
whatever [ __ ] excuse i at that time i
had problems but
even now i don't have those problems
and as soon as seven o'clock starts
i'm trying to make an excuse because i
know i only have an hour to cancel
and then by like nine i go [ __ ] and i'm
gonna go down there and as i'm driving
down laurel canyon the whole [ __ ]
time
i'm like i hate this [ __ ]
i hate this [ __ ]
you know what i'm gonna do tomorrow i'm
gonna wake up in the morning i'm gonna
[ __ ] call my age i'm gonna tell them
to cancel the rest of my [ __ ] work
and i'm just gonna do ten podcasts a
week with lee i'm gonna do sports and
jumping and hunting [ __ ] humans i'll
do every [ __ ] show
imaginable and then i get down there and
i've been working on something all day
like i've been working on a joke
but about a week ago i wrote something
in the back of a page sideways
like i didn't even write it correctly
yeah i just
was talking to lee on the phone i wrote
it sideways and for some reason at the
six minute mark like the previous [ __ ]
last week
i remember that i put
i got home the other day and i was so
frustrated on burbank boulevard i didn't
get stuck behind one preppy
prius
i got stuck behind two priuses
which is hell at about three o'clock
when you gotta be
and the whole way i'm cursing at them
and they're pulling it's like they were
playing a game
one [ __ ] fruitcake would do 45 and
the other guy would do 48. they were
tormenting my [ __ ] life
by the time i got home i'm pissing and
i'm waiting
and i got into the bedroom and i caught
myself how mad i was
and i real prius then
and i never spoke about it again until
last tuesday so on the way home
i'm thankful that i went down there yeah
you're following me and i'm always
thankful there's mornings i get up and
i'm like listen
i never wrestled in high school so i'm
horrible at jiu jitsu right so my
friend's class is at 9 30. my lungs
aren't ready for nothing at 9 30. you
know and i go to jiu jitsu and i get on
the bottom and after three minutes i
think my head's gonna explode and i tap
out and i get up and i run around
and i go back in and i do it again for
two or three times i get keep getting
choked up yeah but as i'm walking to my
car i always tell myself jesus christ
thank god i didn't let myself get talked
out of coming to this class today
exactly because i wouldn't have learned
that move or would i learn where to put
my foot you know right so every time i
don't want to do something and i've
talked myself into doing it
it's been a great thing that happened to
me yeah you know always
i've noticed that more and more with my
life too every time i uh
and it's hard for me because more and
more
you know you got to learn to say no in
life you can't say yes to everything you
know
but at the same time
some of the greatest you know
opportunities and relationships and
friendships and uh
whatever you call it have happened
because
i just was like oh screw it i'll go you
know i'll go have a beer with that guy
that said he wanted you know he wanted
to buy me a beer or whatever you know
you go out and you realize that this guy
really needed you there or you know he
has this great idea that you've been
thinking about and he's got the way to
make it happen you know what i mean just
a little thing like that uh just taking
that little step
and uh it just leads you down a whole
nother path you never even thought you'd
been on you know it's just crazy life's
crazy but uh
but yeah those little things like that
you talk yourself out of that you know
and it's just one step backwards instead
of one step forwards you know
well it just goes to show you sometimes
what you miss in life by not just
trying yeah you know it's uh
yeah i'm very happy i
i tried different [ __ ] you know this my
hometown is very political
and i used to see people all they live
by was every four years
they would back a politician
and that's it and even now today i see
those same people backing
politicians now making videos and
posting them on facebook
oh my god i'm like i'm so happy even if
i lived here and i was [ __ ] starving
it'd be better than being in that
position
kissing somebody's ass every four years
for a [ __ ] job right you know just
just
me taking the chance i live in [ __ ]
california i get up i've been here for
18 years i get up i'm at the green light
i'm at a red light i look around i see a
palm tree
and i'm like i can't believe i'm in
[ __ ] california 19 years
like i still remember coming here
looking around and going i'm only going
to be here for a month yeah i'm not
funny enough to be here you know right
but i'm happy i [ __ ] tried lee you
got any questions
for this [ __ ] hero or what you're
going to sit there you want a brown
[ __ ] star
you're gonna sit there yeah that's crazy
it's just uh
there's been a lot of stuff going on
recently and i i haven't even watched
for the vid videos because i just don't
want to
but there's people now like stomping on
american flags where did you see this on
it's all over the news they've been
doing it for 30 [ __ ] years no but
they're doing like a lot right i'm
talking about football i'm going for
business jumping out of helicopters and
you're talking about stamping americans
yeah it's just [ __ ] up
i want to hear about this i don't know
what's the reason behind it i don't know
i couldn't you didn't read the [ __ ]
article i didn't want to watch that
video
i sent it to you it's like i'm on the
phone right now i think it's because
like there's some of the baltimore stuff
like something like that stuff oh okay
so it's just i mean i have two cousins
in the military and i just found out
that one of them has to get deployed
again she's in the air force so she's
not going into like
actual like dangerous dangerous places
but she's a little a little daughter so
it's like [ __ ] up
all i got to say to the flag stompers is
uh
you're welcome for the privilege and the
freedom and the right to stomp on the
flag that gives you the freedom and the
privilege you're right to do that it's a
circle
you're gonna talk about football jumping
on [ __ ] helicopters and you bring me
down i want to talk about stomping on
flags that that brings me down and i got
to go home and light a candle
[ __ ] stomps on flags they haven't
done that [ __ ] in years
children it's [ __ ] up
one thing over
i don't think so i don't know why they
arrested the six cops anyway
who the [ __ ] knows brother
uh
this has been one of the greatest
[ __ ] nights for me on the podcast as
i was talking to you i went through a
lot of emotions
because i thought about the things i
haven't done while i was talking to you
you know i'm still young
and i hope that people also got that you
know i just felt that i hadn't done a
lot of things i couldn't even remember
i just thought of 20 things i wanted to
do when i was talking to you and i
and i talked to you and we're talking
about these shots that you took that
were just enormous brothers so i love
you you're the last
of the real mohicans and uh
hopefully if everything goes well we'll
be watching you on nbc this [ __ ]
winter on sundays all right [ __ ]
yelling and screaming for you man it's
been a pleasure to have you i know
you're busy it's been an honor i know
you're leaving thursday so i just didn't
want to keep here all [ __ ] night
talking about you know the battle of
evermore i don't want to hear about that
i wanted to hear about your struggle man
so lee no questions for the man
that's it well good luck man i got one
last one okay if everything worked out
who did you really no well that's a
[ __ ] up question who did you really
want to get did you have any
did anybody talk to you at the all-star
game that you left there going hmm
i maybe ended up in tampa bay uh you
know i talked to
a few scouts from different teams and
coaches and
you know in the end there you know i had
a couple of options but
it just made the most sense i mean you
know apart from seattle being a great
place like
you know that's the best team in
football right now and it's a great
organization and uh
where is it what what are you doing oh
i'm missing something oh i'm i'm a
patriots fan okay well you guys won you
guys won the game you know you guys are
very good
but
you know this is uh you know if i make
the roster i'll be the oldest player on
the team as a rookie
uh nc in seattle their oldest active
player players 33
you know i'm 34.
so
you know they're on the rise
but it could be good for you like
preseason right like if you if you have
a good preseason and another team needs
a long snapper exactly you never know
exactly so
i'm just going to go out and all i can
worry about is
you know me and uh
and
the things i can't help like my age and
my size and all that stuff [ __ ] that
stuff you know you got heart man yeah
and that overtakes heart and [ __ ]
mind and soul
[ __ ] all this [ __ ] up dramatically
right because just the the posture
the confidence in you the air that you
have right so i felt it when you came in
the room and i felt it the other day man
so i wish you
all the [ __ ] luck in the world lee i
want you to start looking into the
marines i could see green beret in your
future
you know what i'm saying you take a
little deployment we'll deploy you for
five years and you come back and we go
to the church
sounds good
we'll have the man take you he'll walk
you right in tomorrow yeah you'll be on
a plane by [ __ ] sink or the [ __ ]
everlast yeah you would who knows
believe this this
are you listening to this
right now we could sign you up tomorrow
you could be in iraq by [ __ ] next
tuesday doing jumping jacks in the heat
when i left college i considered moving
to israel the reason i didn't one of the
main reasons was i didn't want to have
to join the army
i would not be good in the army yes you
would no you ever see stripes yeah i
asked john candy why'd you join he goes
well i figured i'd lose a couple pounds
and he doesn't lose any weight during
the movie he's hysterical he doesn't
good no he didn't go on a [ __ ] diet
you know
he didn't let the army help him out but
you're a young man if i was 26 i'd go
over there right now for a couple weeks
yeah see what's cracking let them shoot
at you a couple of times
sounds terrible
that's all i'm glad there's people like
you nah there's people like you you're a
savage i've been working with you for
three years you got this i got this i
could see you jumping out of a [ __ ]
plane with a backpack
well he'll push me out of it no they're
not going to push out you know i've seen
it happen they do that they push you out
you don't go if you hesitate who's going
to push this sweet face out they do that
to animals like you not this look at
this
they will put a
soul of a boot in middle of the middle
of your video and kick you right out
thank you again for driving up man if
it's sharing your story it's a beautiful
story thank you we'll close it out lisa
all right
i'm just going to take that what
happened now jesus christ music right
you guys can go happy cinco de mayo
the church will be back tomorrow oh we
are i hope so okay let's do it
uh go to honor.com use cardboard church
to get ten percent off of all the great
optimization products
i'm confusing people what'd i say i
don't know
what's the music i have to do this for
you all right hurry up he's in a rush he
can go he's in a rush okay
um i'll do them after the music